[Music]
it's not the intro it was me oh I did I
did as kinda like a segue really more of
a technical blend hmm we have of course
quarter black yard audio and Gerald a is
here I appreciate him being here my half
Asian Larry bill Richman is not here so
to run interference for me which means
that I have no protection is even
Brendon how are you sir good good good
I'm glad you where'd you get those masks
I got them from origin main origin main
oh yeah this is the guy who climbs all
the trees and the poles and he had no
idea who's going to be in the show until
just now oh well welcome not really
shows put up show your pajamas there
even Brendon did you make the flash silk
selections there are two options and one
of them was like not one of them was not
def Comedy Jam
by the way you and you audio Wade you
could both be a home alone color palette
it's all green in Burgundy and that
burgundy is I think exclusive to morning
robes yeah I don't like colors used for
my anything else other than filthy old
robes like how long have I had this robe
right and why is it why is it burgundy
yeah nothing else wants to occupy that
part of the color wheel everybody from
big robe got together and said no other
work is a sham it's a hoax really some
of them are just shades so it is bug
Club quarantine that's a hashtag use the
hashtag bug Club quarantine so we can
knock out that bastard Jim Acosta I
think he's trending the O code is
quarantine you get $30 off which is it's
a big deal for us bigger deal for you so
he's our primal you're three notes often
go to lot of credit a calm /schedule
every night at 8 p.m. all of April yeah
and of course good morning moon club
Monday Wednesday Friday we will be
talking about Donald Trump wanting to
defund the World Health Organization
Chris Cuomo yeah right uh which is kind
of tough because what do you do when I
do what a POS segment with Chris Cuomo
it's almost like I've explored all the
nooks and crannies
like at this point I had to do
underwater spelunking there are new
nooks and there are no new nooks there's
a lot of no letters Cuomo Chris Cuomo
he's positively convex there's no
nothing there's nothing to unpeel there
isn't even a breakfast no no no none at
all and what else we will also be
talking about
oh just showing some the video from the
best Trump presser yeah up this week
Marjorie your chat let me know if you
would like I've thought about us just
running the Trump press briefings just
because I want to do the job that the
media won't when CNN cuts out from it so
I notice how what we do I was at the
entertainment comedy channel but maybe
here or at Crowder bits where you can
subscribe yeah we might just run off
feed from one of the public network be
awesome yeah defunded so let me know
what you think well sorry do you work
here
look the shake who do you think is
signing the Front's of your checks been
solid not as the Google speaking of
which that's our first story I think
Stevie son can bring it up that Donald
Trump is putting his name on the checks
yeah which people are really upset about
the Treasury said that it won't it won't
create a delay but who knows and stupid
and Donald Trump shouldn't care but
neither should you you're getting a
check that's that you did nothing for
other than stay at home yeah you're
getting a snow day check can we call
them Trump checks no one no one would
buy it I believe your Trump checks you
don't even have shag birds really
quickly let's tune in to see what see
diners go around Sanjay Gupta is there
as well as a canary
okay so we'll get to Donald Trump
defunding who and also will be playing
hipster hobo I should say you can play
the blaze I know the chat kind of sucks
and that it don't give you a username
but just type in your name in your chat
but first always want to thank our
sponsors today's show is sponsored
brought to you by bed people have
beds I wrote this very poorly but we do
appreciate the support bed people has
kindly prepared for the show by the way
and really I don't know how we would do
it here for good morning right yeah
without beds right and you use this
product pretty often almost every day
Wow I use it that almost every day it is
very and for many hours hours a day yeah
so to check out this product go to your
favorite search engine and type in beds
use the promo code eight Z's that's
Google beds or Bing DuckDuckGo
okay this works to eight z8z is very
important and you will get off the line
Brennan do you use a banner Jesus Lee I
imagine you sleep upside down like
mother eating bed 30 minutes ago really
oh that's a great thing to tell your
employer right yeah but we thought you
prepped I put in zero effort call you
man unfortunately for me your genius so
I can't fire you but don't use leverage
this is something that my friend Johnny
boy and I have been doing we chose we
talked about it all fair we even talked
about it on here you're such a narc
jailed if you telling me on this I the
nerves you've always said that you would
tell on me even if I committed a
righteous crime so I I have not harmed
anybody but we hired somebody I would
had a fire I knew that would shut you up
pedophiles
registered sex offenders but one of my
good friends and I swear audio wait if
you sell me out I know you won't
I know you won't because snitches get
stitches which is a horrible message
free community by the way no you got to
go with it Johnny boy and I have found
pedophiles and we don't do it we don't
come in we don't commit any crimes other
than disturbing the peace okay that's
good we drive out in front of their
houses at night and honk definitely
lights run but and anything what about
the other people neighborhood we find
corner lot pedophiles are you serious I
just where to God we have found a
multiple corner lot they do really well
themselves in the real estate market I
would love for there to be some kind of
anybody wants to be a buddy a
meta-analysis of pedophiles on corner
Lots tweet using the hashtag annoy the
pedophile know everyone to do this find
the pedophiles in your neighborhood
someone who peed in a public park I
don't know you can read up the talking
about actual pedophiles guests who are a
harm to others which is why like I'm
Charles Bronson and Deathwish in a new
song the kids probably in there you know
like I don't know watching Dora the
Explorer's and I feel good because I
know I know I made his life more
unpleasant what time do you guys
typically do this as the light as we can
which for me me about 10:30 wouldn't you
and I wouldn't be serving the community
in accosting pedophiles properly if I
tried to go any later bender how this
little bit would have gone if if bill
had been here your lawyer told him you
said it was a good idea said it was good
yeah we're good yeah we're gonna what do
you think about it pedophiles honking
you don't think I don't know all right
so let's get to the first story
President Trump wants to defund the
World Health Organization I don't want
to say that this show influences heads
of state but we were kind of early on
the China thing and World Health
Organization and then you see it kind of
it was sort of paired it on Fox News
from people who were not talking about
that even beforehand and then Donald
Trump's like you know away I think we
should look into the whose no [ __ ]
I'm not even gonna leave the crib that's
too smooth for a mouse that's the Grinch
reference so let's watch us go to the
clip for people who missed it that he is
going to D fund the World Health
Organization I love it today I'm
instructing my administration to halt
funding of the World Health Organization
while a review is conducted to assess
the World Health Organization for all
severe I'll review of the world bring up
spread of the corona virus everybody
knows what's going on there I think
everybody knows it's going in there I
know they told me not to say Chinese
pirates
oh man must've slipped whoa whoa I'm so
sorry we were half a second away from
that happening we're going to review the
world galaxy but the Milky Way wouldn't
take part in the census so a couple of
things that was something that I loved
about we absolutely should by the way
and like it really clear as to why
before I get into some of the fallout
which is just delightful really um I
don't want to say the press is not the
enemy of the American people that's what
that's what Stalin said people try to
attribute this quote to Donald Trump the
press he's I think he said that now
since I defended him which kind of you
know shouldna said it if he said
communists are the enemy of the American
people that's unlike McCarthyism I'm
fine with it by the way he was right
about a lot of stuff it wasn't totally
wrong okay the communism is the enemy of
the American people and communist
sympathizers are the enemy of the
American people that means the World
Health Organization and that means the
media who carries their water if you are
a member of the media and you are
excoriating our president at this point
for simply saying that we should defund
the World Health Organization you're a
communist sympathizer there is Team
America and there is team communists who
don't even acknowledge that Taiwan
exists so when when given the option of
funding communist propaganda or not
usually I choose to will do not yes yes
well you shouldn't forgive us for for
looking at history and saying well look
this is a failed I have the ideology
that leads to millions of its citizens
being killed and oppressed and typically
ends very poorly in world war so yeah
well will not go down that road if you
guys can just like report the ninjas
having a great time so just a couple of
times and in the realm of America every
single time that happened I mean it
happened it happened like you know what
30 years ago it's not like 40 rounding
but in the realm of history we look back
at like oh you look back at the Romans
in the Ottomans I blink you're talking
about a very large gap compared to how
long we it's been since our last World
War it's not that long do you know when
world war ii was there bringing
forty's hey there you get about right
pretty close so of course you have the
leftist politicians they've been
completely outraged and going to bat for
the World Health Organization none other
than Jim Acosta love it
I always count on him who took it so far
to say that Donald Trump unfairly blamed
the World Health Organization in China
now the key the operative word there is
unfairly right because it would be
unfair if President Trump blamed the
World Health Organization in China and
they had freaks like nothing to do with
it right like if if they were completely
innocent that would be the Italian flu
yeah right if it were the Luxembourg
sniffle right that's a valid point but
it did come from China China lied about
it and the World Health Organization
said don't worry you can we'll help
we like you thank you very much and
willing me with this morning show here
right is he live is he still alive I
don't know if I can go through that mask
somebody give this guy phones we've
talked about this quite a bit if it
existed in a vacuum the World Health
Organization right if it just existed as
though oh they kind of suck they said
some crappy things right no it doesn't
context matters Taiwan warned the World
Health Organization of the dangers of
human to human transmission in December
in December and they ignored seems like
that information would have been helpful
it seems like a whatever help seems like
they denied the claim they denied the
claim saying that they said that Taiwan
never did that and then Taiwan said oh
yeah I think we have that if they
release the emails this has nothing to
do with this destination this is my live
raid four beds promo code lives you
wrote that transgender on CNN right now
if that's the problem are the whole
LGBTQ ap never gives them the benefit of
the doubt wait wait boys wait for the
voice if there's an above average
amount of makeup by some particular yeah
virus that that gives you immunity
myself but I am another know with a
little bit of mic feedback yeah which is
you know Adam's apple reverberation
rights do you like surprises
yeah no no I did not in my morning news
for when yeah one of the things about
this is that Donald Trump did you know
we can say what we want to say he didn't
just defund the w-h-o he basically said
we're gonna stop all funding to do a
review right which he could still end up
going back and saying alright we'll fund
them I doubt that'll happen this is the
first step towards defunding them but
that's a reasonable thing to do to save
whoa whoa there's all this evidence that
these guys were bad actors in this and
they should have done their job better
we're not gonna fund them until we
figure that out why is that controvert
it's entirely accurate because the
Chinese can't act they're very bad
actors like Jackie Chan was their best
one he was her past his line back there
MVP now I know you're gonna say that's
racist sure so I don't yeah agents are
really bad actors I think when you saw
Kim jong-il died that entire nation
deserved a Razzie yeah and that's
certainly not shed a tear you know a
Native American because a little bit of
trash by the roadside oh yeah that's
tough to find that job hard to fill yeah
I don't know how much of it as they were
indoctrinated how much of the like they
bought the propaganda sure but it's so
you have to know because it was so bad
at the art of acting they'll be killed
yeah that's the whole can you think of
any good Asian actors Brendon I guess
Jet Li's and what oh yeah yeah he did a
great he's some great work with GM and
or yes yes it was an experiment and
here's a good thing there's a new poll
out too because I mean it's is they just
been torching obviously any of their
credibility and that's important to note
remember right now because I guarantee
you four five six months from now
stories are going to come out about the
World Health Organization corruption
where everyone else is going to
acknowledge it just like after the story
Jonel Trump didn't want to send
ventilators they didn't need 40,000
ventilator
no place on earth at this point I don't
know about other no place in the United
States I should say I don't think I'm
needed an event needed 40,000
ventilators New York City topped out of
4,000 okay 4,000 so they covered it
saying Donald Trump doesn't care about
States doesn't care about people dying
he's not sending out ventilators and now
where they do they just move on when it
turns out they don't need the
ventilators this is what they'll do
right now they defend the World Health
Organization why because they hate
Donald Trump that they can't help
themselves
when you do know that the World Health
Organization like they're parroting
communist propaganda points and they're
you know they refuse to acknowledge
Taiwan it's like no III know because you
don't Donald Trump I can't help it
there's nothing there's nothing I could
do
he said they don't he said he didn't
like them I have to defend them which
Donald Trump has got and say I don't
like Hitler and just watch them tear
themselves apart limb from limb so just
just so you know it's not just us sure
millions of children your children our
children out of school because of this
pandemic many still don't have what they
need don't have Wi-Fi don't have
computer do they have moms they can
learn so oh that's right you hate that
you're not on the board with the mom how
do we learn before Wi-Fi how did we
learn community one can anyone give me a
book report on how fire was started a
water for charter schools I know this is
wrong but what what do we do during the
summertime when the same exact number of
kids are out of school oh oh no I don't
know I know that there's no daycare and
stuff so that's the caveat but I mean
come on
what was that beat what was it wrong do
you clean up your brain here like I know
it's wrong but summer vacation I'm sorry
there's no daycare for people who are
going to work that used it during the
summer so daycares done yeah but daycare
doesn't isn't feel when you're home all
day and you can care all right I get
that yeah margarine laws and dads still
work from home sometimes so I'm saying
there's caveats and even Brendon I'm
hoping this might be one of those things
where you catch something we miss
because
do you know what he thought was
offensive in that statement no but I
guess I don't see his point though
because look summer is supposed to be
only three months not like the whole
year ya know my whole point was that in
summer the exact same number of kids are
out and we deal with it for three months
and it's not that big of a deal oh okay
so I see you were talking about my chest
we were John guys we're still like
you're playing chess in a pool Stephen
yeah play chess so I know we were
talking about how will they learn they
can learn no I know teacher one time we
got mad at me in the third grade for
missing a class because we're going on a
family trip they perfect do you really
think that he's not going to learn more
traveling across North America
yes been sitting in him lying there
he'll find out what happened to the Big
Red Dog like we can tell him yeah
spoiler we can tell him once we pass
Toronto okay it's not that big of a deal
so we again all this is designed when
you look hot to Sarah McLaughlin thing I
can't even look why do they do this why
do they do this we get it rescue a dog
and buy gold and bedsheets CNN we
understand your target market it is just
so userís I can't look at it right now
90% of Republicans 60 60 percent of
Democrats and 70 percent of independents
believe that China is responsible for
the spread of the virus corn the most
recent Harris races yeah yeah that's
seventy percent yeah actually it's 75
percent Oh independent okay
[Music]
okay what you sent it's not me don't
trigger it's not me yeah that's uh
I tell you it's not well it's almost
like YouTube doesn't care who's watching
anymore
I don't like it so I guess yeah 70 I
said 75 at 7 I said 70 he shot it yeah
yeah it's 75% of evidence you know I
actually had this happen a long time ago
when I talked about the Detroit
unemployment rate being 27.8% oh and I I
don't know it was Washington Post who
fact-check me like no it's actually 28.2
oh I stand corrected they corrected me
the next day it went to 50% in Detroit
whoa let's not concern ourselves with
minor details and the article was
probably like steven crowder gets it
wrong again I get it wrong very often
I'm not going to lie this is very
commonly missing here Oh whole pose
wrong in my selection this morning
that's true that's true he goes way back
actually I do this is remarkable to me
that that the media has no understanding
that the American public don't trust
them and don't trust a World Health
Organization yeah they feel like they're
the ones that are the arbiters of truth
that are out there just like putting it
out there like oh yeah of course they
everybody trusts us we're out here doing
our job and standing up against to the
lies of this no I don't even believe
that this administration you don't think
that no I think they I don't think I
think at this point they're going oh
people don't trust us we're circling the
drain and so let's just go full tilt
leftist and then ask for a bailout I
mean that's possible no it's what
they've said all right they want to be
the next story is are you ready for this
Brendon you don't even have a username
in water you need some wood you want
some what you want some milk I would
love some milk all right let's get
Brenda someone now let's get Brendan a
mug full of milk maybe they don't know
we hit that'll help him be the
breadwinner I took care of for a week
and a half at my house after me oh yeah
remember I remember when you thought you
what you thought you had to amputate
your leg he was like oh I can't wait
doesn't work anymore just turned out
that he had tied the knee brace way too
tight well it was way more purple than
what you have going on right now
yeah but I don't have anything going on
with my knee right now so you mean it's
more purple than a standard skin color
yes it was we were trying to solve this
problem with Brendan he had a knee
surgery from standing and he was over at
my house cuz I like we can't just live
and I appreciate it he wanted to come
into work that day
I really had knee surgery that's not
gonna happen now so he came in our house
and he had to sit there and we took care
of him for about a week yeah and he was
gonna eat my blegh really hurts and
we're trying to figure out what's wrong
with it if we have to call the hospital
yeah what we need to do elevate his leg
and he didn't tell us that he'd
ratcheted it down like a like a
campervan why would she and put on a
hitch and then finally lift up his pant
legs and it looks like like like I would
imagine like Kathy Bates varicose veins
like spider veins but you know the veins
of fat people yes particularly old fat
women my aunt had that that's what your
leg looked like yeah and he just didn't
think to let us know like oh wait maybe
you should know that I tied it down with
a rope yeah and then used a hockey skate
ratcheting tool it's not putting a
tourniquet on my leg would actually help
it yeah exactly so I thought the best
thing was to entirely stop blood flow to
the area right to ensure healing I read
a medical book from the 1800s and they
said if I believe myself
he does not have an understanding of
human growth factors and all silly
Brendan but I'm glad okay so this is
something I wanted to talk about because
I realized that everyone else got this
wrong okay yeah everyone else including
everyone here or saying did you see how
funny the presser was on was it Tuesday
no was Monday Monday night so this is
when Donald Trump presented the video to
the media of what a crappy job and go
his gift to them he was his gift was his
gift to us really yeah really
yes and it was remarkable but most
people saw if you were watching a main
feed first up if you're watching CNN
they cut the feed yeah of course so who
here's been watching the briefings at
night
I've watched about half okay yeah I just
saw the video later online okay the
video from the wonderful this is
wonderful knowing that in case I get
something wrong that one of you can
correct me if you're using the crib the
clips that I've disseminated they could
be incorrect or interesting so the funny
thing is with this presser that Donald
Trump gave people saw the video yeah so
you saw the feed of the but what you
didn't see unless you watched a cheap
sort of local Fox affiliate stream which
is what I usually do
local Fox local CBS you know media that
shouldn't exist anymore I just want to
enjoy the last few yeah yeah of Fox 5 I
was there when they wouldn't let the
Arizona yeah or could be a CBS 6
Flagstaff they have a wonderful they
have a wonderful beat reporter yeah
whose name escapes me so if you watch
from these local affiliates they don't
have the budget for you know the Michael
Bay camera swoops and so all they have
is one shot yeah it just doesn't feed
and so they didn't show the feed of the
video they showed the actual whole room
with Donald Trump presenting this video
with a timeline presenting it to the
media and here's what's so amazing about
this and we'll just we'll play this and
I want everyone if you haven't seen it
what's amazing is that he is doing this
with the people who are being
highlighted in that video as morons
in the room looks at them and points at
them so this is yet you need to this is
the kind of thing that everyone needs to
be seeing you don't just want to see the
Windows Movie Maker crappy video made by
a White House intern that the
entertainment factor here is watching
Trump present it's like the inception of
[ __ ] of Pettit Teddy [ __ ] irate
but it's wonderful so let's play this
clip from the oppressor on Monday now
with that I have a couple of interesting
we have a few clips that we're just
going to put up we could turn the lights
a little bit lower I think you're
probably first everyone let's get some
nice ambience I'll ask you some using
them in because you're so guilty but
most importantly we're going to get back
on to the reason we're here which is the
success we're having okay please you
could put it on more concerned right now
with the flow in this country probably
more concern about the cameras the
reality is comparing it to the flu for
example it's not even close to being at
that stage what if it is worse
this is good I like this a little pride
aside and do we have US officials Shui
wait for it wait for it fashion such as
yourself get involved how worried should
Americans be about coronavirus toward a
virus is not gonna cause a major is the
United States and now I don't know who
did the editing which was like we don't
need transitions look at this watch
watch that's moving timelines it's a
Skrull worked hard on that to the United
States for the next 30 days I wish I
loved anything as much as Donald Trump
loves watching himself watching it says
one point look someone in the eye yeah
none of these weird transition this was
it's amazing that this was actually do
you think he could hire you know the guy
yes Peter Berg remember that quote
remember that quote you little pisher
there's nowhere to hide the idea was to
halt the spread of the disease
keep transmissions to an animal yeah and
Pence is just looking forward like he's
absolute right like someone's got to
fold up the flag and put it on a casket
has got that Adam and Eve pose against
the spread of the virus that was yeah
that was yeah I think he asked halves
was Trump's call
he's probably looking at someone who
works for Cuomo right he returns calls
he reaches out
he's been proactive he tilts his head
like that's nice my voicemail is totally
medical unit are you hearing this is
everyone hearing this medical station
get a volume and that's been very very
helpful the president has been
outstanding through all this the vice
president's been outstanding members of
the crowd he doesn't macaulay culkin
like man my parents are in Florida and
I've in New York even the Hispanic
called the few minutes before I walked
in here to say indeed they would grant
that to New Jersey so that's a big step
for us but it's amazing the president
said that I'm so glad he said it you
know that's right you're the one who
said that previous thing I pointed at
you Tuco you out for the lady behind him
is is Italian she touched with her hands
she just had a spicy meatball we make
the best meatballs
keep looking someone to me I'm at about
his five o'clock though the the
president the vice president for doing a
really good job holy [ __ ] it and now he
stopped he walks back slowly look so we
could give you hundreds of trips like
that including Democratic Democrat as I
call them governors which is actually
the correct curve no someone had a talk
with him they did don't like you know
you'd say Democrat but depending on the
context people say Democratic you know I
know terms yeah I don't I don't know no
I don't know terms I make turn I'm
reading a new book do you know his car
the art of the terms
so many terms it is just to me it is it
is Petty and childish and exactly the
punishment that this medium is they're
Petty and childish too so absolutely it
is like you having your nose rub in the
carpet where you bend and so so many
people were like I can't believe that he
would do something like that in the
midst of this crisis that he would go
out there and start off a press briefing
I was like have you watched what you've
said right mr. president what is he
supposed to do this is an honest
question what is the president supposed
to do when the media constantly lies and
mischaracterizes what he says and does
is he supposed to just say well maybe
you're right maybe I am a bad guy right
when he's not wrong no he can say look
you guys said what you said you didn't
hold not because I think Brennan's
buzzing in waiting Brendan really wasn't
okay it was about functioning buzzer
yeah thanks Brendan this is not a drill
yeah I really I get that it's Petty and
it's childish in the way that he did it
but it was absolutely what they deserve
yeah they need someone who just simply
is is simplistic I don't I don't think
here's the thing Donald Trump is not a
dumb guy
no people can say he's bombastic Donald
Trump hasn't aged right since he's
become president even if you compare him
to Barack Obama George W Bush he came in
as bombastic is not super articulate but
he is surprisingly quick on his feet
sometime he absolutely is and this but
it's not gone away
think about Penton so what was saying
Wyden could be president for eight years
but look he's mean for playing for them
what they said yeah right and that's
really at the end of the day that's what
we're saying is that the president how
dare he play them what they said well
yeah they either have to show their own
words on their networks all right and
look like it is CNN right now they're
chyron says Union pushes to zet
designate grocery workers as first
responders it looks like it is the my
pillow guys ghost of Christmas future
with you in the freezer too long was
that what your need look like playing a
used vacuum bed pulled up they dragged
him out next to Walt Disney's corpse
macri's on to his bones real bad news
hey hey hey Walt we're gonna put whoa
hey watch well wake up we need to put
you next to Sanjay Gupta because his
makeup artist is on furlough yeah we
need to make him look better by
comparison Union pushes to designate
grocery workers as first responders as
unions would no good yeah because when I
think first responders step aside 911
firefighters who are running directly
into the rubble there's someone at the
Piggly Wiggly who has to checkout my
density ice I got to restock the pickle
aisle oh my god I can't time and a half
what stupid things are they saying did
he just say something about about this
for a second
this should be the main story right now
not only that we we are not we are
potentially not funding the World Health
Organization but hey here's why the
World Health Organization is basically
an arm of the Chinese propaganda
Communist Party and instead they're
having a guy to talk about grocery
stores first here's the thing I think
the grocery store clerks great we should
get in asks no problem with it but it's
amazing to me that this is the coverage
right now I understand you don't want to
cover the fact that you were bent over
and effectively costed like joe biden
circa 93 thousand 19 what you talking
about how uncomfortable that would be to
be a member of the press and have the
president
show your mystia show your quote saying
this is this is not as as bad as the flu
and then look you in the eye like
remember it I remember Joe he's like
pointing with a little pointer Jim is
this you all I'm doing is playing what
you said Jim is that you right oh I see
what you did you played a clip of me
yesterday out of context well guess what
two can play at that game
only I'll include all the contacts
because context is what makes you
so diabolical Purdue yes show me on this
doll what you screwed mentality like
that he's going to call them out every
single time it's hilarious I feel like
you just put it in a weird place that's
where you must be doing yoga showed you
chairman destroy yourself I appreciate
your commitment Jim know what when it
comes to screwing themselves your tab by
the way do we have some we have my club
take that before we go to a traffic
we've got good morning guys obviously
what face is the name is not a real name
good morning guys as you are a coffee
guru Stephen and because of anxiety and
caffeine sensitivity do you know of any
decaf copies that don't remind me of
Wade's joking about them you know so we
can put some distance but do not a
physician I should have read this before
yeah thanks Gibbon I don't know a whole
lot about decaf because I'm a man so I
know you have decaf it black right I
don't drink decaf and I assume if
they're if they're decaf is as good as
their other blends then it's probably
plenty good decaf you tend to lose
something because of the process I don't
know I'm just not a big fan so I have
anxiety and I just I just I just drink
through do you drink through I drink
through it I power through it with more
cast like an alcoholic me like I'm an
alcoholic but I drink throw off to the
other side but yeah yeah let's see good
morning if you could roast any president
who would you choose thanks for the
morning show guys this is Rost any for
us so I don't put them on my roster or
something you were too busy scanning two
lines I don't reference your obsession
lot Harry if I could roast any president
I don't know I understand
I've thought about this because they
asked me to write at one point I don't
know who it was to write for the
gridiron dinner sure not the
correspondence or that's well no I'm not
gonna write for someone else I mean I'll
show up and do it and instead I think
they like rich little or something you
know what is raven sound like tell me
Frank trevally no so uh I don't know I
mean I would like I don't know if Donald
Trump has a thick enough skin to laugh
at himself yeah that's probably true
what is it better that you like somebody
that you're roasting or that you dislike
what's which way makes it easier
probably the best would be Ronald Reagan
he seemed to have the best sense of
humor about himself I guess you know who
would I like to roast the most Jimmy
Carter um just because typically like
there's kind of a rule in comedy that
nothing is off-limits why did you just
say really because he's the Georgia
peanut farmer why would you assume
Mellie why are you attributing motive
for detail okay so there's no G there's
no DHS there's no chess and he's not
even playing checkers 14 he's playing
backgammon on a checkers board but he's
wildly entertaining himself he thinks
that he knows what the chess is I was a
backgammon board I win every time just
say it and that's like the commercial
just say just think the commercial is
just I win he thinks that the rule to
the game no I said I win but you woke
daddy he clearly but I said I win um so
a Jimmy Carter and the reason why is in
comedy there's a rule that nothing is
off-limits
except the helpless okay yeah so that
means typically like you know people who
have obviously disease like terminal
illnesses or people who are you know
mentally ill thing the mentally [ __ ]
people but all of that goes out the
window because Jimmy Carter was
president yeah so it would be the one
time where I could not that I have a
dream of laying and - mentally [ __ ]
people right but I would be able to see
what works when making fun of what a
mentally [ __ ] person yeah mentally
[ __ ] face Oh Jimmy Carter a few
months back there was a time when Jimmy
Carter was in the hospital because he
had a bunch of pressure on his brain and
a great joke show I think we did I think
we cut it right you know like it was to
me it made it there goes the sponsorship
from beds they won't touch us no more
that disc host yeah I love how relaxed
Brendan is right
perk you up yeah you don't drink
caffeine do you know the coffee machines
too complicated so I don't want to touch
it
yeah it's a button it's you quite
literally hit a button right but to
clean it is you don't have to clean we
don't drink from it then I won't be
expected to clean it what are you
talking about no one expects you to
clean anything if only because we don't
trust you
we don't want salmonella this guy's
brilliant we do have a question that
includes something about coffee right so
if a page says if President Trump
reopens the economy too soon do you
think it could potentially cost him
votes in November
also what coffee brewing method do you
use in the studio keep up the great work
I don't think that he can reopen the
economic parts of the economy too soon
at this noon I think at this point many
parts of the I think at this point we
need to determine what is non-essential
what is essential actually on the
opposite we need to determine what it's
all right no wait what is non-essential
wait what am I saying because I was
watching that timeline said would
remember when you that Donald Trump
could do this remember what you said
essential but you meant non-essential
are you sure you wanna roast me I can
show many clips of this I have your word
whisker they're gonna like put a song
two hours in April which the quality
took a nosedive frankly I was surprised
you did that we were all surprised you
even put did you even put Brandon on the
show after he was still on painkillers
[Music]
what is non-essential in other words
well the only industries that should be
shut down we should only be quarantine
in people who are vulnerable old people
been saying this all along yeah old
people people who are already sick
people with diabetes quarantine them
because that'll also benefit them long
term if we develop some kind of a herd a
herd immunity yeah this a herd mentality
it's not a good thing
a herd immunity but that can only happen
if this runs its course it is going to
run its course no matter what one way or
the other right the only thing that
we're doing right now is slowing down
maybe over overpopulate are over running
the hospitals which really isn't
happening right now and maybe it's
because of the efforts but I don't think
he can lose votes but I think that the
media will look for every single
possible opportunity if he opens no
matter when he opens the economy up and
I know we say that he can't technically
do all of that it's really gonna go down
to the states where it should be to say
hey this is what we're gonna do yeah I'm
fine if New York in California stay
closed a little longer they have more
cases than anybody else
yeah so that's totally fine but I think
what they'll do is like they'll look for
the one iced wanna make sure that you're
99% sure that I know New York has they
have to whether they have one third of
all cases in the United States wait hold
on a second all a second experts warned
400,000 could die in Japan if virus
isn't contained you want it again really
guys this won't just watch that number
go down like Ferris Bueller hacking into
ed Rooney's computer yeah guarantee you
it will not be poor nerd they love
London I guarantee you and I don't even
know I don't have the numbers in front
of me I'm just willing to I'm willing to
stake my reputation on it all the day I
will roll the dice 400,000 in Japan okay
I don't guarantee you but I'm pretty
sure yeah I'm relatively sure
as far as coffee you know we have an
automatic we have a Juris presto machine
here it's the most expensive non camera
equipment that we have because black
rifle is a sponsor so that's what we use
in the studio and then at home I usually
use a chemical over things so keep it
pretty simple or sometimes I use the the
individual pour over so that is the best
way if you want good coffee to just do a
pour over if you can't have an electric
kettle you control the temperature it's
pretty easy or ghetto otherwise I have
to get a really expensive coffee machine
let the mr. coffee Black & Decker if
it's under I would say if it's under 150
dollars it's not getting the coffee hot
enough ah do we have we have a traffic
update right we do have a traffic update
I was going to say we we actually have a
breaking news story at the top of the
map regice and a toast no yeah so China
urges the u.s. not to halt its funding
to the World Health Organization so
China has an opinion about this yeah
well listen China if you care about that
so much uh you first how about you fun
yeah why should we be subsidizing your
organization or how about this China
okay
all right China how about here are the
rules first you acknowledge Taiwan you
apologize you cut the debt in half that
anybody owes you at this point you pay
reparations and you start funding the
World Health Organization and you know
what how about
test few bucks into NATO then we'll
consider we will consider taking any
this is what I would see if you do all
of those things then we will consider
not ruining your day by messing up your
entire government how about that hmm I'm
at this is as close to an act of war
what China has been doing at this point
as we have seen in the modern age think
about the Cold War and what we were
afraid of obviously nuclear weapons
that's already happens now at this bread
China just needs it but China just needs
to buddy up with the right people by the
way you know don't like to not like you
can't even find a nuclear weapon in the
side of this hemisphere idea um and it
is remarkable that this is just more
proof they expect the United States to
to front the world health care bills
yeah medical innovation we're the ones
you have to come up with a vaccine and
we're the ones who have to fund the
organization that lied to us about the
disease and denied the only information
that was actually accurate in December
because of political motivations when it
comes to Taiwan why would we ever take
part in anything the World Health
Organization does why should we care and
China even more please do answer me this
why should we care what you think even
if there's 19 billion of you now Donald
Trump looks like he was a not prophetic
but he could see the future like he was
pulling out of some of these deals with
China on purpose and saying these guys
are really really horrible we shouldn't
be dealing with them this way and it's
because I oh my god he was looking at
them objectively yeah and not bowing to
everything they want I'm bringing up the
article now as this is breaking so I
apologize ya know the number of cases in
New York and domestic airline travel TSA
screens lesson what is this oh okay well
here it is right during Wednesday's
press briefing in Beijing Chinese
foreign ministry spokesman Zhou do John
said this Donald Trump authentic I would
have thought that Brendan would chime in
there ever since he said Jet Li fan I
don't know that that means he can speak
Cantonese by the way the fact I said
name a good Chinese actor and he said
Jet Li yeah do you have any shame I put
a black dot that is on your country's
history it is China imagine that like if
they were like can you name any good
American actor and just some American
students ago he run like a girl video
gently
good
you know that's all just a fad same
races Chinese for mystery talking lousy
Sonia now now now Ching I don't know I
don't care is that that's parently
that's racist now to hit it like make
fun of the Chinese language just because
I know how to pronounce it yeah even
know with anything I can do with Italian
and we do we do but in the Italian
really yeah yeah to a racist so Donald
Trump decision they've they've Donald
Trump's decision to cut u.s. tranship
contributions to the who this is comes
from ABC News right to the World Health
Organization would impact all countries
across the globe especially the more
vulnerable ones yeah yeah yeah you mean
like Taiwan well and you mean like a
pandemic yeah China China yes thank you
for paying attention how about you help
the most vulnerable countries in the
world yeah they're not saying hey the
World Health Organization helps the most
vulnerable countries in the world what
they're saying is the World Health
Organization entirely relies on the
United States subsidization to fund the
most vulnerable countries in the world
China why don't you take care of them
any Islamic nations by the way pick one
ever are they helping the most
vulnerable countries in the world why
does it fall in the United States Canada
your own national defense go well we
wouldn't have time to make the Orville
Redenbacher before you guys be speaking
fluently in another language we need to
give you health care we need to give you
security we need to over pay into NATO
and then now for some reason we have to
pay a propaganda wing of the Chinese
government the World Health Organization
or it's our fault that people have to
dig wells and Zambia how about you go
screw yourself China just do a little
bit we just want you to do it how about
you start with your own people by the
way why is it it's peaceful why is it
our job to help the most vulnerable
elsewhere but we cannot help the Chinese
not to mention that you won't even allow
us to help the Chinese by being fair and
bringing in our guns to China they don't
have access to it they have to make the
goods that get exported but you can't
let them get the quality stuff you can't
let them get the stuff that they want
because of course you've a class
structure right yeah you
use your own people and you want to call
out the United States to fix the world
and the most of all and I get it this is
the expectation because we've always
done it and this is why it's so fun no
one here you know what they're not
saying you know what this is not saying
lady in town Hong Kong what you're not
saying is that the United States is an
evil empire we hear that all the time
right Unites States is an empire when
can you imagine anyone anyone can you
imagine the mongolians going hey yeah
China could take down the wall it's kind
of tough for us but oh sorry my bad my
bad no no could you better go to the
Roman Empire some someone who's under
there some of them just saying hey you
know what you're not doing enough for
the people across the globe I don't want
my my job I know the Roman Empire the
Greeks the Ottomans but I know exactly
what was happening outside of their MPL
you're not all I mean a lot but what are
you doing for Ethiopia that's an old
place there you go no no you don't say
that to an empire you say but please
don't rape us and pillage our stuff the
United States is the only world
superpower by the way the only world
superpower who fled the world's greatest
superpower one century to become the
only global superpower the next century
and we've left places better than we
found them I know we're gonna say hold
on a second what about the Middle East
you're right it's a quagmire but that's
because the government's there are run
by animals yeah well and it's been a lot
of people but the governments that
neighbourhood was screwed up before we
moved in yeah okay it was really bad in
Kandahar they saw United States Marines
rolling in and said there goes the
neighborhood yeah exactly property
values looks like the Bronx well and I'm
confused China wants they want to have
all the influence that they can with the
whu-oh this is your golden opportunity
China step up they want to have the
influent they want this this also tells
you how much they expect the American
media to be complicit oh they wants the
influence but they don't want to front
the cash and they're hoping that Jim
Acosta reads this or Stephanopoulos gets
a hold of him let's prepare to show that
you're one of the top economies in the
world you pay the three hundred and
sixty million dollars that's the
difference between what we pay in what
you pay
oh you think our economy is no no no
American misunderstand economy is house
of card
our years and centuries of human rights
abuse it's not work when you when you
when you take away that house of cards
you know house of cards I do
yeah what China just do me a favor and
talk to Russia the USSR about this
because we did this game before and they
yeah there you're gonna that's good
for a little one-act yeah little one-act
about Watergate so weakens the whose
capabilities in harm's International
Cooperation well okay this sounds bad
it's like the political compass test
will be taking okay harms International
Cooperation uh who are we supposed to be
cooperating with hmm
doesn't that matter it does huge ears or
any drinking milk with his mask is it
through the mask drinking through the
cheese mass I feel like it would just
run down his shirt we should probably
find out before the end of the show at
present the global pandemic situation is
grim and is at a critical moment so told
reporters we urge the u.s. to fulfill
its responsibilities and obligations and
support slots ability to lead the
International combat against the
pandemic guess what that you had art to
cooperate with you I want nothing to do
with you zero this is amazing to me it
would be like Nancy Pelosi reaching out
you know the same person it was like
dancing in Chinatown saying hey we're
trying to town strong come on it's just
allergies it's just it would be like her
saying hey let's cooperate to Donald
Ryan just cooperate in the impeachment
why would I ever cooperate with that
yeah I I have an idea here I'm willing
for the United States to go ahead and go
back to the level of funding for the
whu-oh that they were before China you
open up completely you don't get to tell
us what the numbers are in your country
you give us full access this is like the
what of the atomic stuff the IAEA right
no we dropped that on Japan no no no I
that didn't I know that like even open
the country up for us let us see what's
really going on I don't understand I
don't understand why the I know exactly
why the expectations are gonna stay so
you don't we'll do the traffic update
we'll do it later because we're actually
I didn't realize how late we're running
Oh
all right so then we also get the
hipster or hobo that's back it is it's
bad so now let's get to this other issue
is anything else anyone want to chime in
on China at all oh my god what's
happening on CNN
taraji P Henson creates free virtual
therapy for black communities well
that's nice
what virtual what do you mean virtual
therapy I don't are those eyebrows
painted on
I hope they might be they probably are
is it odd that what's your name
poppy what's your name poppy Harlow has
to pretend like she's taking this whole
thing seriously
[Laughter]
I first misread Henson character it's
Taraki P Henson was something that came
out of the creature shop not a racial
thing where she happens to be your guess
is as good as mine I mean because of the
hair and the eyebrows if we had a
protractor I'm sure we could tell where
those eyebrows are having if you look at
the door off into the horizon line your
makeup artist shouldn't have to factor
in trigonometry equations right to make
sure the tangent I'm just worried she's
a judge though can you do trigonometry
Brendon I bet you he can I bet you
Brennan probably think about that by the
way to think about it it's not a trick
question
he didn't say like what's five plus five
and you're like uh ten he's like do trig
right now yeah I'm not asking to do
trigonometry romantics pencils graphic
calculators work together ti-85 it's an
expensive way to spell boobs
you didn't upgrade your joke the new
calculator that you can rat them out
well have grabbed up a good joke is a
good joke oh hey you know I do have a
story this happened today oh my gosh you
know I'm up somewhere between 3:30 and
4:30 a.m. and not not because you taught
you Jocko are you getting after Ivan I
do I make my own decisions you're not
the boss of me so um I was up very early
and I Drive you know I just go for a
driving a drink my granite coffee in the
morning I wrote inna I listen to the
news and I have to be very careful
because I listen to it usually NPR right
does thank you mad no I fall asleep at
the wheel
to change it without their news maybe
sleep more no no it's actually it's just
NPR it's unbelievable they're they are
federally funded to be boring okay so I
was driving and then I I stopped it and
I hate to my everlasting shame quick
trip come on you have Chuck Norris doing
your sponsor this show I am the biggest
advocate for QuikTrip why because I grew
up in Montreal well we don't have
anything like that I've ever everyone
meet my wife used to mock me because I
just loved quick trips okay look at this
gas that you can get anything you get it
you could even get gas and she's like
this is why is it so amazing just like
found like a grocery store
well that's a fact Montreal is an island
and that's very astute so I am the state
lawrence river here i'm sure you're
familiar with the waterways and the
walks not at all okay fewer parts of him
the only familiarity I have with Canada
is like Scott Pilgrim yeah don't say
that out loud cartoons yeah yeah
cartoons this poorly made film well it's
not a cartoon so what was I talking
about before the oh so I stopped but
unfortunately this morning there was
only a racetrack nearby I needed to stop
because I had a problem with my Magos
leaking instead so so um what I was
doing was wanting to carry out any trash
at that racetrack again racetrack not
even close to quit trip if I have to
stop and go into a 7-eleven
I honestly contemplate blowing my head
off every single time it is so bad
yeah yeah I mean oh it's terrible it's
terrible like I said I won't do it with
a Walther I will make sure if I ever
harm myself I'll do with a competitor's
firearm because I don't want to I don't
want to besmirch their reputation I want
to sell their good name so maybe it'll
be like like if I go into it if I have
to go into a 7-eleven ever again I just
I hope there's a Ruger nearby that's all
I hope there you go
yeah so I go into a racetrack and I my
wife left one of those fizzy waters
they're coconut which tastes like suntan
lotion it's like I'm drinking the
subject of a Jimmy Buffett song coconut
Laphroaig it's disgusting or what's his
name Kenny Chesney you know you know
except the ones only the ladder is
closeted gay got me into a street fight
by the way we know that story because I
can teach SEO that you don't talk about
Kenny like that and like oh oh he's your
Kenneth you're on a first-name basis I
so coconut fizzy water I'm carrying this
stuff into the trash but accidentally
you know I have in some of its spills
yeah on the crotchal area
oh so and this happens and I'm always
like I don't want to since I often get
recognized particularly at gas stations
people feel like there's this weird
connection so they can just talk like
for 20 minutes
right I don't know you and I probably
don't even like you
well you might boss you never know well
cuz often they're not people who like
are watching right now know you've seen
me on television or something they'll be
like hey man I I do I do
insulation for premium homes well I
don't have a premium home and I don't
use insulation I mean you don't need any
banks and then I go get my big gulp so I
actually pour it and as I'm getting out
of the car I noticed that it looks like
a crotch old stick like a piece like
I've urinator myself yeah and I walk out
and there's this girl who's Latino I
don't I don't know if she's Mexican
could be Honduran I don't know yeah
we'll just say latina olive skin tone
yeah and she looks at me and she looks
at me like she looks and she goes
because the door opened up and I was I
was playing NPR very loudly and because
that's what has to keep me awake so
she's your vault open I opened the door
and she looked at me like this and does
that answer right away without thinking
oh I actually like I think I acted like
I because I wanted her I thought she's
only seen it for a split second so she
doesn't know what's happened you know
truth is happening right now so I
actually like oh and dropped more on
myself what so it didn't look like I had
peed myself
so she loves she goes looks down and was
quick thinking I'm like she bought it
she did bought it yeah cuz I said donde
esta bathroom and she was like over
there so she knew that I needed to use
it otherwise she'd be like why do you
care so maybe maybe you have more pee
that you drank we were able to cut it
off and then I went in and someone's
like it was a black lady I just all the
interactions happen to be with
minorities the black lady it's at a
racetrack behind the like the custom
food section goes yeah somebody
it I'm kid not it looks like you dropped
it because he would've loved that
no he was I would have made his morning
this may seem like going backward but
Kenny Chesney is actually short for
Kenneth Chesney
really yeah and that's short for
peter-puffer so by the way how much time
do you actually spend in gas stations
because most of us go I believe we can
like is this your like story you walk
the aisles and hangouts loiter around
going I do I look and see what new
energy drink selection because there's
there's like they rotate new energy
drinks more so than the magazine stand
Oh like what's this Oh bang that's
pretty Oh Celsius this is new oh well
this is a new one and then you realize
it like they're the reason that a lot of
them are sort of rotating is because
they're entirely illegal Cola
there's nothing wrong with just the
caffeine guarana ginseng but my dad you
look the first pre-entered pre-workout
was something called ultimate orange and
that was uh was if it was a fedra that's
super super close ephedra is illegal now
but a Fed Rin you can get in certain
like over the counter like decongestants
right and ever my dad taking this
because some idiot at the gym you know
my dad played hockey he always worked
out he's always been in shape but you
didn't even drink coffee now someone
just said hey take this ultimate orange
it'll help you work out my dissing that
sounds like a good idea and he took it
and ever my dad going okay bye see I'm
going to the gym it was called planet
muscles early in the morning and he
walks out and less than one minute later
he walks back in and just lays down okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
his heart was gonna beat out of his
chest oh wow so that happens with energy
drinks anyway but I peed I didn't
telling a story was very Garry Shandling
asked and so she thought I had peed my
pants
and instead I poured the Waterloo all
over my chest it was cold and that's my
gambling I was sitting there listening
to Garry Shandling I received a story
you don't know because you don't follow
entertainment no I um oh that's right
that's right
transformers 4 is there another one what
is this so let me see here Oh Chris
Cuomo okay place your hope I had no idea
we walked through 45 minutes of this and
John King what happened John King and
Sanjay Gupta or as it's known a viewable
self unhook it's like if there could be
a book teaching you how to develop the
opposite of charm yeah it would be
co-written it will be written by John
King forwarded by Sanjay Gupta I can't
tell what I can't tell which one's
darker I just hit my own micro know what
this thing's done to me oh boy maybe you
started it so he's no strike Chris Cuomo
and I love this because I love Chris
Cuomo but not for the reasons that most
don't Chris Cuomo he this week if you
hadn't been following he trashed his he
trashed his job and but not the way that
you think saying that he didn't want to
be involved with hyper partisan politics
anymore
didn't like will play the audio clip but
the context here is he actually thinks
that CNN is not left enough so that
changed what let's roll the clip of good
old Chris Cuomo I don't want to spend my
time doing things that I don't think
that are valuable enough to leave our
soul namely pain Chris Cuomo well you
done see a ting I don't like what I do
but neither do we Chris yeah I like
doing this show I like talking to you
guys but I don't value indulging
irrationality hyper-partisanship
I don't think it's worth my time and I
don't want some jackass loser fat tire
biker to be able to pull over and get in
my face and in my space and my place I
don't want to hear it somewhere there's
a Hells Angel at joke's on you my tires
standard but who's gonna throw Travis
Terry
Bob [ __ ] so here's what's so funny you
guys all heard that right and I want to
make sure I know sometimes we tell jokes
on a comedy show and someone's like is
that a real story that was Chris Cuomo
that was not anyone I want to be very
clear is everyone in agreement that that
was Chris Cuomo and you heard him say
certified even Brendan yeah speak louder
I can't hear you through the mask yes
whoa calm down
whoa so then I think it was yesterday
he walked it back this is a direct quote
says I never said it I never meant it
first off if you never said it okay why
would you need it especially I didn't
mean it I might have said it showing all
the bases Justin can you understand how
recording systems work Chris Cuomo like
did you not see Trump's press conference
right yeah I was sick I forgot have I
showed you my lungs yet my x-ray my
x-ray and looks totally normal
diagnosis from doctor was much shows
signs of being a [ __ ] that was yeah
that was it's been they came up with
that diagnosis so fast it is remarkable
to me that this guy said that right
there and then just I never said it I
never meant it what ha this just shows
you the lack of accountability he thinks
that if he doesn't say it on CNN it must
not exist
all right on some kind of a podcast and
I can just go on my network and say that
I didn't say I think he was being honest
though I think this is a guy who really
wants to be a hyper-partisan he doesn't
have seen it as a hyper-partisan enough
because he's never seen to Laura
Chiron's because he didn't have a
monitor so he and what he was saying is
he wants to push back against Donald
Trump he wants to be more of an open
leftist ideologue and it's not worth
this time they don't pay him enough
but I think I know why he walked it back
because this talentless hack actually
makes six million dollars a year
what for CNN six million six million
dollars a year just for him he should
just give the World Health Organization
I think it's a write-off Wow
by the way I don't know that's entirely
confirmed because they have my like
black celebrity net worths for some
reason black celebrity net worth we can
bring this up maybe it has me listed at
four million really are you a black
celebrity no I don't know why the club
property in Dallas Texas well that's not
true for anyone it's not a fake news for
me it's not true for anybody Lake oh by
the way by the way the random biker guy
he rancid but I guess was an actual
person he planted about it leaned
forward and filed a police report he
caught cuomo this is violating
quarantine and coma had a meltdown and
told them that he'd find him seriously
oh he's right there
well here's the thing here's the thing
you hate bullies chris cuomo bicycle
guys i got a seikar yeah well the reason
I thought bikers could he said fat tire
bike early motorcycle no you're right
but he's dumber than we thought and so
he's talking about a cyclist who had one
of those big fat no I've never done
anything violent all's problem I would
Chris Cuomo I always want to say
governor but you haven't earned that
you're the brother of a guy who did it
and as metal ring so we don't know what
you do I'm will say I would welcome you
on the show and I know I don't expect I
would be respectful civil but I don't
expect you would be so we can also just
have a you know Wrestlemania for all I
want I don't care
and I also you know I've noticed that
there's this trend with Chris Cuomo
where he always plays a tough guy
you know when I called him Fred I was
like hey man that's an insult to your
people
that's an insult to your people it's an
insult to my people no no it's bushy
down the stairs not a racial epithet
yeah I threatened to push him down the
stairs and right here you told the biker
that he would find him the good news
Chris Cuomo I understand what you're
yearning for all of us are you're all of
us are longing for human contact during
this quarantine the good news for you
Cuomo is I am incredibly easy to find
and very willing
very well on one day's notice not only
will I host you on the show but I would
gladly allow you to find me and in a
sanctioned match it could be baby
cheating to by the way there's an
interview here where he's talking about
how he does CrossFit and how he trains
MMA but where he trains MMA is more like
street defense like it's really tough
I would love to test the theory let's
see if it's working for you and then he
tried to accuse people of being bullies
hold on a second you get paid six
million dollars a year to go on CNN and
a guy catches you violating quarantine
which by the way you have espoused
should be against the law right he blows
the whistle on you and you threatened
him with violence on a nationally
publicized program which you then walk
back you are the definition of a bully
you punch down and then walk it back
when someone above you at your network
punch is not really punches down but
spanks you and says no no piss come on
don't be on the carpet so you punch
someone in the industry yeah and then
you immediately cower when someone at
CNN tells you you can't do that that's
way out of line don't say I would love
to hold you accountable Chris Cuomo I
wouldn't do with brian Stelter wouldn't
be fair and there's a reason for weight
classes Chris Cuomo and I exactly right
in there he claims he's 220 work for a
debate
I support work for a bully big bully me
just bully me Chris Cuomo bring it I saw
I was confused honestly when I first
heard the the quotes and everything and
I saw some of the stuff come out I
thought oh well he's not gonna go as far
left anymore he's tired of being a
partisan hack right but no he wants he
wants to go further left right I mean
has he watched I mean really if you've
watched any media if you're working at
CNN or MSNBC do you not watch the other
people to kind of see what's going on a
little bit there is nothing that I can
think of that is worse than him on CNN
maybe Stelter is worse on CNN than he is
yeah and maybe Tapper at times but makes
things worse is Stelter is the fat
closeted gay Chris Cuomo that's you can
see a lot of things about Chris called a
lot of categories the only two things
you can't say about him are that he's
that he's morbidly obese and closeted
homosexual yeah but you can say that
about brian Stelter which is why I
wouldn't want to fight him wouldn't be
fair that would be punching down yeah
you don't want to do that yeah it will
be punched I get down I understand
punching in and then trying to retrieve
it from the amoebic mass that is brian
Stelter is just I bet you
wouldn't be very hard to suplex he would
cause it'd be like grabbing grabbing a
giant bar of selective Lana I I hope he
goes as far left as he wants and ends up
without a job I don't hope he ends up
without a job I do it he goes that far
left I don't want him I don't want him
on the news I I would like Chris Cuomo
to just you know take a pay cut to like
a quarter million a year and watch him
soil himself the rest of us come on
nobody could live on that too busy
threatening bikers and guys in in pop-up
tents of what was it look like a circus
masseur I'll throw you down the stairs
man okay good that's a tough move you
think I'm just gonna react like it's a
Lifetime movie he never does it have we
ever seen Chris Cuomo have we ever seen
we've seen plenty of video they've heard
plenty of calls from Chris Cuomo from
people who could do nothing about it
yeah or have no interest in doing
anything about it have we ever seen
Chris Cuomo respond to someone
challenging him or challenge someone
scarier than him we've never seen it
ever he got really really really pushy
in that video by the way when somebody
finally stood between them then he was
like all right hold me back that's right
better hold me back I've been doing
Crossfit bro I've been doing those
pull-up thingies were you like swings
I've been doing have and do and not pull
up pull off I've been doing pull ups
where I completely remove the LAT from
the equation and it's just a violent
kipping movement and my lower back is
pretty sure but I spat it Uncle rhabdo
[ __ ] uncle rats really good at swimming
in like the dolphin motion yes exactly
that's true I don't know no I don't do
breaststroke or set I only do butterfly
stroke why cuz it's hard but you know
how to swim normally no I don't even
have never learned I'll die
I do Jacob's Ladder bro what's that it's
like a really hard ladder come at me
okay if you insist by the way hit the
notification bell weed if they get going
will go to hipster hobo here in a minute
read some of your chats hit all
notifications because the descriptions
don't mean a whole lot on YouTube and of
course do consider joining up at ladder
of credit calm slash mug Club and please
renew because we're not monetized on the
YouTube this is all that keeps it going
and it's been really fun to interact
with you guys and read your chats of
course our wonderful sponsors well you
know wall third try the walther that's
always say and that's what we need to
say they said
to say firearms they are cool
beautifully designed and deadly they
don't need me to sell them they took
that sell themselves yeah they're like
cigarettes point point and shoot that's
like this guy on CNN $200 was it the
pergola yeah the Sun Center awnings
Stephen designed dangerous at Rachael
Ray it mostly doesn't provide shade
because Sun typically comes in at an
angle so it depends if it's going from
an angle of course a black rifle coffee
the world after coffee calm slash
Crowder enter the promo code Crowder you
get $20 off and this is really this is
my favorite roast it is unbelievable I
really like it and I've told you this a
long time ago I hated black rifle coffee
and the reason why they came to be a
sponsor a year ago and I said no because
I purchased a bag of their coffee at a
gun store in Michigan and it was old and
stale and this is like all this like I
paid for crap and then finally someone
said well just you need to order it
roast it I was like oh what a what a
world of difference yeah and they're
pretty sure now about who can carry
their stuff so I apologize I just you
know I prejudged you I judged a book by
your ass old in the in the B room of a
gun range cover that's known that it was
it was right next to the nine-millimeter
was like I you want it was like a you
know I throw in a bag of coffee might as
well yeah it's gone on forever
okay you know what I actually think
we're gonna get me more checked if we're
gonna help you let's bring up a couple
more chests and then I'm gonna play
hipster hope I want you to play along
with us yeah we even done this in a
whole long it's and that's largely
because we had to remove all spot the
training videos from YouTube that was
one of the condition is to still not be
monetize anyway so I don't know why I
don't yes of what you should so Braden
says hello from Nashville love the show
question for the whole group I've
noticed conservatives slash libertarians
seemed to have a more finely tuned BS
radar than Democrats when it comes to
news stories and life in general we are
more skeptical by Nature why do you
think that is I think it's really simple
and I think the World Health
Organisation I think this whole World
Health Organization debacle just shows
it for what it is in that the left
believes in the value of the collective
over the individual and any kind of an
inny ology that values the power
freedom liberty of the individual over
the collective is by the very nature
going to be individualistic yeah so and
this is what's this is why it's so funny
when people say oh I'm not left-to-right
I take them on an issue-by-issue basis
like there's some some kind of a free
thing but that's what conservatism is it
is actually being an individualist and
understanding that every single person
is different now we tend to share the
same values of course on free-market
principles on what the legitimate role
of government is but the reason that we
believe in shrinking those roles and
shrinking taxes and shrinking government
intrusion any kind of public intrusion
is because we understand that
individuals should be left to make their
own decisions because we believe that
they tend to do it better than a
bureaucracy in Washington DC now keep in
mind let's look at this right now a
climate change now the message you've
been sold right between right and left
is from the left from people like Chris
Cuomo who granted he hasn't been hyper
partisan enough apparently apparently
can somebody please throw that man a
lifeline yes God let it be more partisan
um they say well you deny science when
really the conservator is saying hey
hold on a second planet can be warming
humans can be contributing I just don't
think that the Paris agreement is going
to fix it and I don't think that China's
going to play ball so that's an
individual look at the issues you have
plenty of conservatives who who actually
think that maybe it will support that
policy of plenty of conservatives who
don't think the earth is warmed beyond a
catastrophic amount any of flinty of
conservatives who think that humans are
contributing all different kinds of
conservatives on that spectrum the left
what do they say is you deny science I
mean so once again what do you think
about the arguments I've presented I'm
gonna trust the scientists oh ok so
let's run the World Health Organization
let's look at this yes
SARS number two epidemic because there
were SARS number one this is the sequal
right we say hold on a second I'm not
quite sure if we're gonna get 2.5
million deaths because I'm look at the
death rate right now and you can't
really account for this with mortality
rate in the testing rate and we don't
really know who's been infected yet and
the left says it's absolutely gonna be
2.5 well hold a second what about the
issues that I just I just brought up
I trust the scientists they say 2.5 oh
now they're saying a hundred thousand -
and 40,000 I trust the scientists why
you trust a little or they're still
absolutely right well I'm telling you
now I think there's actually a problem
because if you look at the individual
death rates and it was mortality rate of
6 percent 7 percent now it might be
point 0 4 percent when you take into
account people without pre-existing
conditions and bit oh it's 60,000 now so
what about that 2.5 million I still
trust the scientist
why do you hate science they look at
every issue from a collective lens and
they defer to Authority consistently
because they believe authority has it
right that's why this pandemic they
believe that the CDC had more money we'd
be aces yeah so it's very simple it
boils down to conservatism
libertarianism we value I'm doing see my
left your right see this is it was a
good stage I know the stage stage left
stage terms here see right here up stage
right there down stage
so um my left your right libertarians
conservatives by nature value the power
and freedom of the individual of course
it takes a village right that's Hillary
Clinton's book yeah well I don't think
it takes a village I think it takes good
parents yeah and one of the things that
we don't subscribe to as conservatives
is there is some kind of elite class of
people who know far far far better than
anybody else what what is good for us
and how to implement it right we
understand that and if anything we've
learned this from small businesses
around the country and in technology
that there are plenty of people that can
be experts in their field that have
great things to contribute we don't need
it to be the top person we can talk to a
lot of great people well they always
think they always think that it's some
ruling class who's going to fix it right
it's the right person I will say this
and I really do respect Joe Rogan for
having taken his licks you're saying he
would he didn't say would vote for Trump
by the way that's a Miss misreporting
right about Joe Rogan said he said he
would probably prefer Trump over Biden
but you know what this is the idea that
you see from the left flick well it
needs to be the right person and his
primary gripe was biting said you know
the Democratic Party they made they made
made us all out to be morons when they
pick this guy yeah why didn't burn make
you out to be more he's gonna smooth
over all the wrinkles that are wrong
with the current democratic parties they
are hidin is the problem if we had what
if you read Bernie put point to a
candidate I don't say we'd be fine if it
was Trump no I'm saying I'm actually
grateful that we have a president who
wants to give more power to the states
who wants to give people more money in
their pocket rather than taking their
taxes I want the guy who doesn't really
need or want the job and Joe Biden
desperately need this job because the
other stop it's the old folks home
that's nice
pergolas we saw them on CNN yeah but
he'd rather be relevant until the state
atonic okay we have to go right now to
not to a commercial worry are going to
play for the first time I believe in two
years
yeah hipster or hobo let's go no what
just happened stop just just froze on
the guy we try it again
[Music]
ever ever
yeah it's hurts this is worse than SARS
and it was not most about kovat 19 is it
I panic I can't make SARS jokes anymore
maybe we should take the intro to well
but no we you first
it's like China domain we fund the World
Health Organization you go first Brendan
but you do can you sing it for us that's
got a bit come on it will destroy the
value of I mean you were awful but it
was a good idea Brendan can sing notice
that even I thought and with a mask on
he would he's the man singer okay so for
clothes don't know can we play the game
though do we know if those work oh yeah
okay okay we completely so for people
who aren't familiar this is actually and
those are striking this was two years
ago now kind of everyone else knows this
striking similarity between hobos and in
hipsters to the point where it's almost
difficult to tell the difference yeah
it's almost impossible and so what is
going to happen right now is is a
quarter black Garrett an audio way they
are going to show us a picture over
again and we are all going to have to
guess if it's a hipster hobo yeah and
the one with the highest score gets
absolutely nothing in return
Oh gets to end this program sir
alright let's go number one let's see
this okay is that a hipster or a hobo
nice mug what do you think Brendan
hipster hobo looks like a hipster trying
to look like John Snow
I'm thinking hobo okay I'm thinking hobo
cuz the the long hair he's got that yeah
yeah I'm gonna go to hipsters okay
here's what I will say here's what I
will say I am going to say hipster
because I'm looking at that tumblr and
I'm seeing a two-tone it looks like
underneath his pinky it's a different
tone like it could be a Klean Kanteen
gonna found it or it could be a hydro
flask so I'm gonna say hipster alright
[Music]
that one is a hobo indeed just
third-grade math no GED I was right in
my assessment that's a hard oh who does
take great at the apiece great attention
to drink where yeah you were hold on so
he was wrong you are right by Turkish
he's getting all the let's show us
another one that's a trick different
that's a trick we probably shouldn't
play the clip on that one I don't know I
don't know you know I hate that I hate
that I've been put in the position right
now we're have to make a judgment call
without all the information available to
me because we could lose our jobs but
yeah I'm gonna call it we're gonna do it
I think that is a transgender hipster
hipster because I cannot afford the
hormones yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
one is a trick joke you see he's matter
of just a trendy this I appreciate you
looking out audio I was you threw me a
lifeline and I was like the guy you
threw me the lifesaver and all drown
wash the taste out of our mouth and that
one okay I feel like this one is so
obvious it's gotta be I'm sure that I
should go
alright there are no lenses but it's
just cuz he can't afford the lenses
that's either a hipster or Ted Bundy I
can't tell here's also that here's also
the wrench that's been tossed into these
plants that could either be a hipster
who purchased Warby Parker glasses or it
could be a hobo who was donated Warby
Parker glasses that's a great point yeah
yeah yeah there are just tons of hobos
walking around with TOMS shoes and Warby
Parker Glee are and we thought it was a
style statement it's not it's not set if
you go to skid row you're like it's an
outdoor this is a coffee house no it's
just just wonderful companies it's a
compassionate cap did you get these for
free or for $300 I think it's so obvious
that it's a hipster what do you think
Brendan I feel like it's trying to be a
trick question yeah so I'm willing to
bet it's just you think it's him Sir
oh yeah straight hit I think I don't
know I don't you could be right you see
you're playing for DJ's here you think
oh that's my job no you're a teacher you
play backgammon with a wall um yeah
that's hard I am going to say that it is
just a very attractive hobo oh okay
let's see well kept
that one is a hipster you see you should
have known by his Fairtrade team is
wrong I couldn't know that is T was
Fairtrade mr. baby got it alright it
takes a photo and lifts the blue curve
to get rid of the blacks just like
that's it what's wrong
computers ok let's do one more let's
call it a tie breaker or anyone is
getting this right so let's see this
last one trip sir hobo you can play
along with us well that's not fair we're
not even seeing facial features I'm
gonna say that beards to quaff did neck
is G nice the neck is clean I don't
right wait wait a second we have seen a
single hobo yet sponsored that's right
it was that it was the hobo slash Yeti
cooler model right yeah um I'm going
well then in that case a chit I'm going
to say hipster here hobo okay going home
what do you think we think I'm going
hipsters okay alright I love how after
yes what do you think he's asleep knows
his home he's a dark horse in all of
this he just can't cook spaghetti
noodles well no he burns them to a crisp
cowboy why did you try to cook spaghetti
noodle he just threw them in a pot no
bother really
Irie little bit it's incorrect to call
them spaghetti noodles it's not correct
at all yeah mostly because it was
actually a penne it wasn't spaghetti at
all
he thinks that spaghetti is a synonym
for pasta okay we all agree we all say
hipster let us know
[Music]
that one is the hipster indeed he wears
well Scouts in 95-degree I also know why
we didn't played this before because it
is entirely a gross violation of
copyright copyright of trademark
infringement and the entire Paul Simon
and Garfunkel catalog as well as just
human decency so alright well listen do
we have any chats like a good chat to
send us out otherwise we're just gonna
go out and do that personality test yes
so if Joe Biden gets lost in the woods
who would you like to see is the
Democratic frontrunner thank you for the
extra content
Jordan T okay I will say this I would if
Joe Biden can you do that again if Joe
Biden gets lost in what to see as the
Democratic nominee okay I would like to
see whoever drove him out and left him
in the woods yes that is the person
legacy because it would give us at least
a Democrat in a little bit of hutzpah
yeah this someone has to recognize a
problem at that Prop his thy name is Joe
Biden so I'm going to drive him to the
ozark and let him fend for herself which
you know he can't yeah he's not the 11th
person who I want to be and of course we
know it can't be Bernie he can't drive
because cataracts so my guess is it
would be what's his name what's his name
you big dog Francis oh no so there you
go I want bring me Francis bado O'Rourke
because he did a good job dropping on
Joe Biden off in the Ozarks that is what
I want to see that's the level of
political discourse okay we do have to
get going tonight we will be taking the
political compass quiz because you asked
for it I'm not happy about it and of
course the live show tomorrow at 8:00
p.m. a lot of clutter calm /schedule so
you can follow us we'll see you tonight
thank you
[Music]